combien y at-il de députés à l'assemblée
nationale voici les réponses en 1993
un nom la quarantaine c'est bien plus
que ça autour de ça un petit peu plus on
s'en approche
je gère mieux tout mais je veux pas vous
répondre ok il y à 577 députés en france
et à la drogue d'autres manières aux
députés
ce jeune homme le disait en 1993 et
c'est encore un avis partagé aujourd'hui
577 députés à l'assemblée ce nombre n'a
pas bougé depuis 1986 mais avant 86 le
nombre de places dans l'hémicycle a
fluctué
regardez en 1958
cinq cent soixante dix neuf députés ce
nombre chute à 482 en 1962 conséquences
de la décolonisation
puis repart en légère hausse en 1973
avec la réorganisation des départements
franciliens et lyonnais chaque
législature en effet est un nouveau
départ avec des données nouvelles
alors comment en sommes nous arrivés à
577 députés en 1986 c'est une décision
du président mitterrand il augmente le
nombre de sièges à l'assemblée en même
temps qu'il instaure le scrutin à la
proportionnelle
résultat la majorité de droite n'est pas
toute puissante et l'extrême droite
entre dans l'hémicycle on bricole
essentiellement aux extrémités de
l'hémicycle mais parfois est menuisier
en quelques états d'âme
je pense que ce soit pour l'extrême
droite ça ne dérange encore plus nommé
premier ministre jacques chirac supprime
la proportionnelle sans revenir sur le
nombre de sièges de députés
toujours 577 depuis alors est-ce que
c'est trop en 2013 des personnalités
politiques de droite comme de gauche
remettent en question le nombre de
parlementaires députés et sénateurs
confondues
aujourd'hui à environ 1000 parlementaire
en france on peut faire moins
à une condition c'est de renforcer les
pouvoirs des parlementaires qui
resteront un parlement resserré mais
plus efficace en 2017 c'est le projet du
président macron passés de 348 à 244
sénateurs est de 577 à 404 députés car
aujourd'hui à moderniser notre maison et
577 députés
de toute évidence est un peu trop pour
travailler ce que veut faire emmanuel
macron le voit bien c'est concentré
toujours plus de pouvoir dans les
cercles technocratique et les français
en 2018 ils étaient 80 % à être
favorables à une réduction du nombre de
parlementaires députés et sénateurs
confondues
[Musique]